19 états on fait scession l'armée
américaine intensifie ses actions la
Maison Blanche met en garde les forces
de l'Ouest et l'alliance de Floride le
président qui entame son 3è mandat
assure que ce soulèvement sera
rapidement maîtrisé ditoi si vous voulez
essayer quelque chose vous êtes au
courant qu'il a une guerre civile qui se
déroule dans tout le pays nous ce qu'on
veut c'est rester à l'écart avec ce
qu'on voit aux infos c'est ce qu' a
mieux à
faire chers
américain les soi-disant forces de
l'ouest du Texas et de
Californie on subit une défaite très
importante face aux forces de l'armée
des
États-Unis monsieur le Président est-ce
que vous regretter l'utilisation de
frappes aériennes sur nos
citoyens aujourd'hui ils avancent sur
Washington on doit aller là-bas dans la
capitale il tire à vue sur les
journalistes mon instin me dit qu'on va
y
rester chaque fois que j'ai survécu à
une zone de guerre j'ai cru que ça
servirait de mise en garde chez nous ne
faites pas
pareil pourtant on y est je crois qu'il
y a comme un malentendu quoi on est
américain
d'accord d'accord quel genre d'américain
vous
êtes vous le savez
pas
les forces de l'Ouest atteindront la
Maison Blanche le 4 juillet c'est pas
vrai dans la voiture montez dans la
[Musique]
voiture rest en dehors de ça c'est h de
question une seule nation sous
l'autorité de Dieu
indivisible avec la
liberté et la justice pour tous allez
allez allez allez
allez que Dieu bénisse
l'Amérique